roberto 25 ans est en pleine séance
d'échauffement se retourner la tête pour
lui c'est une habitude si tu le fais
trop après toi maman
deux fois par semaine cet étudiant
mexicain à l'université de nanterre
pratiquer son sport favori la lucha
libre est un dérivé du catch
aujourd'hui l'entraînement se complète
d'une initiation son cobaye c'est carlos
un ami mexicain visiblement il ya du
boulot
ta main gauche ici sur mon épaule
la main droite là est ce qu'on va faire
c'est ça
découvrir les ficelles de la lutte
mexicaine à l'évidence ce n'est pas dans
les cordes de monsieur tout le monde je
crois que j'ai encore besoin de pas mal
d'entraînement pour y arriver
après l'entraînement direction
sartrouville c'est ici qu'habitent
roberto avec laura une française qui l'a
rencontré il ya trois ans au mexique et
en bon mexicain il lui a fait découvrir
la lucha libre et
la basse et enfin ça y est énorme quoi
c'est vraiment
la défense et de la folie quoi ça
remplit la halle arènes de mexico comme
ils disent ça a la taille d'un stade
quoi au mexique la lucha libre est une
véritable institution
c'est le deuxième sport le plus
populaire du pays après le foot tous les
jours des combats retransmis à la télé
des athlètes voltigeurs et des millions
de téléspectateurs pour ce style de
catch spectaculaire qui date de 1933
[Musique]
roberto lui est encore loin d'être une
star du ring mais ils en rêvent son père
vient de lui envoyer son premier vrai
costume de catcheur confectionner
intégralement au mexique
[Musique]
rentrez le ventre
non jamais ici seul et c'est sûr parce
qu'on est en france
en france et on peut le faire énormément
c'est ses preuves s'il commet catcheur
perd son masque normalement
il perd sa vis c'est fini pour lui son
carrière ce soir roberto disputera son
tout premier match dans un bar du
quartier latin il ne sera pas dans la
mythique salle de mexico l'aréna mais il
fera comme si les avoir ton maître temps
provenant maintenant quelle honte c'est
à deux pas de la butte montmartre rue
houdon raphaël du haut de ses 5 ans n'en
est pas encore à disputer des matchs de
catch avec son papa musicien est lui
aussi fan de lucha libre et qu'ils
écument les quelques boutiques
spécialisées de la capitale une plongée
en amérique latine qui peut se faire en
français ou en espagnol mais aussi
adorent les masques de catch
à des catcheurs préférés de raphaël
c'est mystico
mystico
ces mini miss tic parce que chaque
catcheur à son à son album catcheur mai
mais un petit c1 qui savent bien que
c'est exactement comme louis oui
porte-clés autocollants collier mêmes
vieilles affiches de match ici la lucha
libre et est cuisiné à toutes les sauces
dans cette boutique des pics de lutter
côtoient des statuettes de la vierge en
plastique bleu ou rose fluo la lucha
libre et ses masques c'est peut-être
kitschissime mais pas seulement
2 les oeuvres d'art quoi régaler des
démarches qui sont faites
avec avec beaucoup d'imagination avec
simple allez blick et c'est une sorte de
script turquie voilà exactement ça qui
représentent des animaux fantastiques et
donc ce personnage là il a repris selon
la qualité ça représente pas vraiment
une partie de la culture populaire
mexicaine une cape de mystico et 15
euros plus tard raphaël et son papa
rentre à la maison boulevard saint
michel avec son mini ring et ses
figurines notre jeune fan joue souvent
aux apprentis catcheur ça c'est les
ciseaux ont l'air après et saute et la
con c'est sa tombe
cette passion pour la lucha libre et
s'entretient aussi grâce au cinéma nos
deux fans ont plusieurs dizaines de
films de pure série z comme cette
superproduction de 1969 là c'est le
clown mais mais le méchant
il va rester l'angem santo et blue demon
les deux plus grandes stars de
l'histoire de la lucha libre et affronte
une armée de monstres avec notamment un
certain un frankenstein
bizarrement orthographié c'était normal
fait que c'est drôle quand on est un
enfant n'y croyait tous et
les salles de cinéma se mettaient à
crier tout
pour raphaël c'est l'heure de se coucher
et de faire de beaux rêves de lutter
à quelques centaines de mètres de là
dans un petit bar du quartier latin
vous aimez le cas
on y retrouve roberto notre catcheur
débutants ce soir il est le technico
c'est à dire le gentil et lors de son
tout premier combat officiel a sonné
m'intéresse c'est fini c'est le roberto
maintennat scepovic lingots qui est la
face à lui le roudaut c'est à dire le
méchant le bien nommé david bourreau
l'évêque cité à san franciso tête il
faut pas qu'ils sautent partout de tak
tak je viens d'attraper boubou
les coups de poing et les clés de barras
enchaîne les planchers de japonaise et
autre coup de la corde à linge pleuvent
là
et dix minutes plus tard sous le regard
compatissant de sa première fan le
gentil bobby chang ho est achevée par
l'infâme david bourg
[Applaudissements]
la route pour l'aréna de mexico est
encore longue